okay so hi everyone just had to let that
finish plan before I started because
there's no way to stop it
welcome to my first playthrough of SCP
Blackard house that was planned I opened
this on find I guess this is the first
common ladder from dr. Miller to a deep
bus to be noisy d-class from dr. Miller
hey d-class how about you stop snooping
through other people's things
lucky for you I'm not a guard or you'd
likely be terminated on the spot for
something like this so I take this as a
first warning and a lesson if you want
to survive your time here dr. Miller
okay let's let's go over and do some
things in okay so we have pick up key
cards to gain access to things higher
levels was higher clearance that's
pretty standard fare Oh check it out dr.
Miller senior researcher excuse me I
can't really edit the audio on this
because it has to be live so anyway dr.
Miller senior researcher ID number 5
double 8 908 that's news to me
yeah his name is disappeared okay
hmm it's a it's a thing spike logging in
okay so II class reception-room see
sector 21 so that's where we are right
now the d-class reception room right
fancy site 50 site 50 I'm like most
foundation facilities where scps
are contained and studied permanently
side fifty serves a different purpose
while site fifty does not hop
capacity for storing large amounts of
see if level SCPs and items the primary
is foresight 50 a student is to
temporarily HEIs study on sort newly
discovered or captured SCPs to send them
off to the best-fitting foundation
facility such site 50 has a wide array
of sectors pills and scientists for
different fields on pipes of sc8 so that
was a bit of a small background on site
50 not sure if site 50 is here as in the
d-class reception room right sector 20
in yeah or worth or if it's where the
game takes place right oops
let's get out of here on just just play
a little bit of the demo oh yeah check
it out why buy the full game check it
out I am in it G mu Dawn's in it what
more do you want I mean that CP
Illustrated probably Lord bong let's
just started you okay let's do this
okay often I guess okay I'll be safe and
these are not part of the game okay so
starting with Moloch snow dr. Miller
SSG alphas your name here major so a boy
ancient ice linen icy plen on Sergeant
John it says it's not part of the game
but I'm gonna pick after Miller's went
up just because cuz it's me okay it's me
Wow
these declaw cells are much more
advanced on our containment breach
tender parts very spooks
facebooked indeed
I'm not sleeping game okay mm well I'm
kind of just tight in the middle of
nothing here shoo this is thing I can
pick up okay hmm let me die secure
contain protect lies the SCP L
foundation that you're something yeah
okay why does my like people and getting
turned off I don't like but I like it
nothing more and that's this
please show how their showers
beware the vents okay like these pens
these vents
oh Jesus
Frank it did say beware the vents I
guess that's that's a thing tonight
that's really really creepy looking if
they are yeah doesn't seem to care about
me though Oh what was that
something came out of that door it just
fell asleep what is that what does that
mean but there's something in oh my god
there's something in there what is this
can I poke this oh that's so weird what
does that mean although at least he
didn't attack me
hello that's a that's a musical change
something has happened somewhere
something has happened somewhere are we
good
what's this swipe card logging in
I can't see one
[Music]
hmm
critical emergency dum-dums hmm I don't
know hi I'm really paranoid not to be oh
wait I have two flashlights her dad
nothing quantity one flashlight but I
have two flashlights I guess that's not
too but that also means that I can't
unlock doors anymore what is that what
what what what what happened what has
happened I'd hear while I've been gone
Oh God
this is ridiculous who's this
this just generates in the level that's
Maude
Wow not as impressive now I've never
seen not in contempt and containment
breach and often like that ever happened
okay there's another thing that never
happened so let's try and I don't know
why I'm moving so slow no no we're good
we're good
got two flashlights that means I can't
get in any doors so that's that's okay
really
that is really creepy so what happened
to the bodies of the thing that was
there so what all stand from him well
that's really creepy looking with art
and the rest of the rooms corrupted my
tea mom I honestly can't see this moving
but every time I turn around its like
consumed more of the leveled this is
just cool mom is it every time there's
like a black eye maybe I don't know a
scene mom the trailer that thing post
you looking thing did I accidentally
leave my my key card here because I
swiped in I don't know what no I have a
feeling this is not really teaching very
very many people like this game it's
just me kind of farting around
really come on not bad it's just cool
what happens the rooms while you're not
even looking I can't really I don't
think I can go anywhere
ah okay do you know what I'm just gonna
go for you I don't know what else to do
he's the he's the only one that can open
doors for my never run out of things
okay
do you know what actually I'm just gonna
leave it here I'm gonna leave it here
and next time it'll be a park to where I
will learn a little bit about the game
then I'll come back to it and I'll play
some more okay so for now okay this is
where the gameplay ends I will see you
later
maybe for a second one but I have to do
washing four more pairs of underwear and
stuff first okay so goodbye I'm gonna go
on home cup of tea and try and relax I
would like to give a special thank you
to the reclusive extrovert GM's sabah
pablo ice 917 kareem el Ashman we travel
you peg white crew and jayvo Jack Bryson
Bailey my archive curator Nick
Tibor bull quarts five six three and the
wonderer thank you all so much for your
support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volga thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you